welcome back to cbs mornings with gas
prices soaring more americans are
looking to ditch the pump and go
electric sales of electric vehicles rose
to 76 percent in the first quarter and
market share for evs doubled to 5.2
percent a company called rivien won the
race to deliver the first all-electric
pickup and is now launching an suv but
there are major questions about whether
they can deliver on their ambitious
goals senior national and environmental
correspondent ben tracy visited rivien's
factory and took a ride with the
company's ceo
you ready
okay it's gonna go quick should i be
scared no
whoa
by now you might have heard that
electric vehicles are fast
that's like being on some sort of rocket
ship ride yeah it's very very quick
but rj skoringe the founder and ceo of
rivian is out to prove they can also be
fierce you'll see why at the company's
test track in central illinois he showed
us what rivien's new electric suv can do
oh we're literally gonna go crawl up a
wall of rocks we're gonna crawl up this
wall of rocks exactly do you often find
yourself climbing a wall of rocks in the
real world
is this just showing off this is just
having fun he calls this an adventure
vehicle kind of feel like we should have
helmets on something you could use to
both tackle a trail and get your
groceries we wanted the vehicles to
truly be capable of going anywhere it
almost seems that you're trying to show
people electric cars don't have to be
these little bubble things that you
drive around in all that was intended to
challenge existing expectations
and to create products that that were
exciting in and of their own right not
just because they're electric rivien has
been dubbed the tesla of trucks it sells
an suv and an electric pickup truck they
are not cheap each costs about 80
thousand dollars but they are unique
from the front the truck looks like it
drove off the screen of a pixar movie
motor trend named it 2022's truck of the
year raving that it redefines the genre
when rivien went public late last year
its stock surge briefly made it one of
the most valuable automakers in the
world worth more than general motors and
ford but the stock has plummeted and
lately the road for rivien has been
pretty rough
it's been plagued by chronic production
delays due in part to a shortage of
parts including semiconductor chips
its sprawling illinois factory can
annually produce 150 000 vehicles but
this year the company is expecting to
roll just 25 000 off the assembly line
the way to get one is now more than a
year long so this blue car what's
interesting is this car has already been
assigned to a customer
thirty-nine-year-old skaringe has been
heralded as tesla ceo elon musk's new
nemesis and in return musk is now openly
questioning whether rivien will survive
elon musk recently said you guys are
tracking towards bankruptcy
what is your response to that you don't
start a car company immediately making
money you know i'd say i think he's
maybe forgetting some of the things that
tesla themselves went through but
i take it as him hopefully just trying
to be constructive and helpful
what's been helpful is the billions in
cash rivian is sitting on thanks largely
to amazon it's one of rivien's biggest
shareholders and amazon executive
chairman jeff bezos gave rivian a huge
boost in 2019 when he placed an order
for 100 000 electric delivery trucks
when will we see them on the road
well we're delivering them as we speak
the trucks are part of amazon's plan to
go carbon neutral by 2040.
in the u.s transportation and the
pollution from gas-powered vehicles is
the biggest source of planet-warming
greenhouse gas emissions scoring says
climate change is the reason he founded
rivien in 2009 as he wrestled with his
two competing loves cars and the great
outdoors especially road trips with his
family so that sort of led to me being
frankly really bummed out just that
these things i loved were simultaneously
the root of so many issues the reason
ribbian exists
is precisely for that challenge go for a
ride and he says americans will still be
able to drive the trucks and suvs they
love so have you done things like this
before
crawl up a wall of rocks in a vehicle
yeah no
and take them just about anywhere they
want i think this is the very first time
i've ever done this
see there we go dave first
for cbs mornings i'm ben tracy in
bloomington illinois
they're pretty cool but you know
in the united states electric vehicles
are less than two percent of sales in
europe 10
so i think you got to get people here
even interested in evs yeah before they
even start looking at something cool
like that yeah but that boost by jeff
bezos 100 000 delivery trucks like
that's big time don't bet against bezos
but 80 000 is a lot for a car a basic
tesla car is 45 000. so hopefully these
cars become more cost efficient but it
is critical to work to improve the
environment so that's right hopefully in
time i like how he was sort of treading
lightly when ben asked him about elon
how's elon beefing with everybody no
it's the playlist again
on the show let's talk about it